okay pay attention so again just to work
the disarm okay
how we got here we're not dealing with
right now
so you want to try to grab the two ends
i have his hand too you see but i don't
want to grab his hand i want to i want
to control this thing
and then you're going to come around
and at this point is when this hand
rolls over do you see
not not not at the beginning
okay control the stick around
then you push it you see how i do that
so we'll go slow
so
control the stick
even if he gives me like
an inch i'm i'm going to take that that
part you see you're you're here like
that
and here
around
roll it in now now that's when i turn
this hand over
this is when i turn this hand over when
i get here
okay and then into him or always into
his center boom
it clearly puts it after that okay all
right so let's try that get both ends of
the stick all right so again we're not
working on how we got here we're just
taking the disorder the concept is
control both ends of the stick okay
and then you we're here we're gonna find
our nico she's gonna grab it in the
middle when she feels that she's losing
it you see and this is when you can do
uh other other locks to this so
um
you kind of gotta expect that so i'll
show you again so i'm gonna go here
well i go here she grabs it right and so
you can come around and look again
do it one more time it's kind of a weird
grab that she did but we'll work with
that one okay
so come around
boom
she grabbed this way and then here is
your other nico right here
okay
sometimes the uh
person
uh will come around this way right and
some of you were getting this thing like
that do you see that okay so this one
you just you're gonna not come down
anymore you're gonna go in this way
okay so let's say you're grabbing
bro okay and then knee heel right heel
and you turn your arm
this way like you did and then you come
back into the arm
and you're just doing the same thing
so i got here oh she grabs on the stick
find the other nico here
okay and you have the stick now so
that's going to be our drill so you
double knee can you try so uh
this time he's gonna let's work with a
pushing exercise
he's trying to drive on get it okay so
he drives and i'm here
so i'm gonna let him go past the outside
do you see but i don't i have to get the
enikio before i get to this hand okay so
on the outside here
there you go he i grab it he drives oh
there it is
so he'll go boom
we'll stick with the two drills boom
the diagonals okay so
wool he dries off he
dries okay let's try okay so
i'm here
right she's pushing and i'm moving
around this way
okay
so push boom there we go
a little slow okay
whoa
hop are you pushing on me so here chris
i'm going to go this way with the jump
with the with the stick so instead of
like trying to reach around here i just
bring it around all right okay and then
there's that nice
door
bring the stick around
there it is brother
okay
all right we're gonna move on
absorb this way you see that and we're
gonna take advantage of this opening
here
we're gonna move it okay
this is gonna go down and you're buckled
up
don't worry about how we got here so i
go one
long
and i'm going to go this way this time
you see oh what technique is keep your
grip right you want lights on it
what technique is this
oh
thank you
right
so don't reach around like this
move off the line the weapons on the
outside like that take go past through
the sunkeel where was her energy going
her energy is going this way so the
reddit your energy's going this way your
body is going this way do you understand
okay
she's running this way you see
so you don't do it so fast cause you'll
bite it okay so whoa let it go past you
okay
we'll do it slow don't worry about it
[Music]
around
boom slow down
around there it is here it is
in you go
whoa
move to the outside out there it is pop
there it is
inside
okay move the joke
or just stay in this case don't reach
for it move it around okay so
what
what like
watch what happens to the nico as he's
trying to do the technique okay
so when i pull when i want to pull this
stick it undoes the knee
you see
i don't have to do anything fancy but go
okay
so don't go so fast that you get knocked
out all right
so
you go away at the end so he was pushing
so i went with the energy okay so i'm
going here and he goes to pull it and
we're going to boom
pop him with the other end
right
where you hit uh yoko man okay right
here on the carotid area
don't miss it
so
somehow i got here
i go pull and go to go with it you see
it right there
so i just go in
and attack the base
somehow i got here
these holes go with
make sure
that the bottom part of your body
has a displacing
factor go away
right there okay
here we go